la question du jour faut-il courir en
ville la réponse est non
non faut pas courir en ville parce que
c'est toujours extrêmement problématique
il faut une attention super coup de
soutenu traversée des rues et puis alors
sans compter que par le fait qu'on soit
souvent engueulé les voitures ne voit
pas en milieu urbain ne voit pas les
courants déjà ils voient pas les piétons
alors les piétons qui courent c'est
encore moins croyez moi vraiment même
pour la pollution
il y en a énormément centre ville c'est
normal une concentration donc préféré
vraiment aller dans les endroits où vous
pouvez être au vert à dire moi je peux
pas j'habite en plein centre-ville alors
ça c'est l'argument quand on a envie de
rien faire parce que kelly bus il ya des
métros il ya des trams et vous trouvez
toujours du temps même le week-end pour
aller trouver un parc où quelque chose
d'arborer où vous pouvez tranquillement
courir faites moi confiance confiance
ayez conscience que ça vaut vraiment le
coup
à bientôt pour de futurs conseils
running